des châteaux la forêt la loire à vélo et
pourtant ce coureur ne fait pas du
tourisme
sa balade au pas de course fait 100 km
bonne voie continuez comme ça athlète à
quinte rien sébastien réussi à fédérer
autour de son défi et de son association
d'aidé aux enfants malades
tout le long de son parcours de 100 km
sa détermination force l'admiration
ça commençait à dire pour ça un peu pour
moi aussi niveau de la nuque
déjà 90 de vélo donc ça commence à faire
mal un peu aux jambes aux fesses
donc voila mais bon on va y arriver on a
un mental avec pia pour l'association va
même s'il faut finir à cloche-pied on
finira le fait et puis voilà c'est comme
ça
avec bientôt deux marathons dans les
jambes un lavoir au bord du chemin fera
office de cryothérapie
on doit toqués mètre soixante six
actuellement donc on commence à être
dans le dur là on a déconnecté en passe
au mental va falloir aller au bout peu
importe le temps mais on va y arriver en
passe de réussir son pari
le coureur de fond a reçu le soutien de
ses amis
tout au long de son parcours pour
soutenir l'association et puis pour
soutenir c'est beau aussi pendant son
épopée
et voilà lui donner un petit peu de
courage il est très fort qu'elle en
arrive aux 70 km c'est là où c'est
peut-être le plus dur donc
ouais moi je trouve ça impressionnant
un samedi très solidaire est un pari
tenu
100 km en 10 heures 40